Rolls-Royce is to go all-electric by 2030.
The news came Wednesday...
...as the luxury carmaker revealed some first glimpses of its debut EV.
The Spectre will go on sale in late 2023 with testing set to begin soon.
Company boss Torsten Muller-Otvos says...
...the brand will then progressively ditch combustion engines.
Current cars from Rolls-Royce are anything but zero-emission vehicles.
Now, though, it follows rival Bentley in making the switch to electric...
...and it's ahead of parent firm BMW, which has set no end date for gasoline-fueled motors.
Back in 1900s, the company, says founder Charles Rolls, described electric cars...
...as perfectly noiseless and clean and very useful...
...if only charging stations were available.
More than a century later, that moment may finally have come.